there's not much Shelter From the
Relentless heat in djibouti's desert
these men and boys as young as 11 have
been trekking for a week from Ethiopia
Dr Youssef Musa is out looking for
migrants every day and knows where to
find them as they get closer to the Red
Sea
we can arrive too late and find bodies
or sometimes people in agony dehydrated
today there are around 40. but you could
find a group of 300 migrants women girls
babies the elderly in April almost 27
000 migrants came through Djibouti
according to the latest un figures since
January the number has increased by 56
percent compared to last year
much of the world is focused on Ukraine
rather than supporting the UN system
that helps the rest of the world we wish
there would be a focus on our region
particularly my country because even
though everyone thinks Samara geranian
is the flagship route of global
migration there are many more crossing
the Red Sea almost all the migrants are
Ethiopian either heading to Yemen in
Saudi Arabia or coming back
at this Center in Northern Djibouti
they'll get the only meal they'll have
had for days
many of the migrants who make it this
far don't even realize they have to
cross a sea the Red Sea to get to the
Arabian Peninsula and they turn back
others pay Smugglers and it's a
never-ending and increasing flow caused
by drought and conflict
Hassan Imam says he's left his wife and
two children behind hoping he can find
work in Saudi Arabia
Dr Youssef says often migrants refuse to
go to hospital because they don't want
to leave their friends
he says he's been coughing for three
weeks and he seems congested so that
suggests pneumonia
then another call for help comes in and
Dr Youssef heads further into the desert
these men and boys are heading towards
the most dangerous migrant root of them
all according to the UN last year 795
mostly Ethiopians were killed between
Yemen and Saudi Arabia where violence
against migrants has intensified
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera obok Djibouti